okay so the polls are in and I'm pleased
to see that you guys reflect this as you
can see it's pretty safe to assume that
the majority of front-end developers are
using console.log the majority of the
time to debug their code and it's
understandable because we've been
conditioned to use simple text editors
like notepad atom sublime text and a
large portion of web developers have
just never really had that exposure or
experience to a formal or traditional
debugging process and the browser
console is a pretty nice way of
inspecting our logs right at some point
it's easy so why would we change it well
because there is so much more
so just sticking to the console for now
I don't know if you knew but there are
heap more methods on that console
objects that some of us don't even know
about console dot table is one of my
favorites it's really nice for debugging
arrays to be able to see and compare all
the different objects in your array and
console dot dirt is one of my favorites
as well because it's really great when
you want to log out the the actual
JavaScript representation of your Dom
node rather than the HTML marker it's
even better in node so console dot log
obviously spits out our objects in black
and white and not super readable and
also it only goes to levels deep so you
can see here the Geo object we don't
really get any information about what's
actually inside that whereas console
doctor we can pass through a couple of
configuration objects options and we get
a lot more readable output and there's
also some really handy features of the
console coming up so this is in Canary
at the moment which is the nightly build
of Chrome which is really useful if you
want to check out what's what the latest
features are but do keep in mind it can
be a bit unstable and a bit slow
sometimes but yeah so for instance here
we have on the left a new way of
categorizing our logs which is really
handy and also you can group similar
logs together so it's really great when
you've got a lot of noise in the console
and it's hard to find what you're
actually looking for
okay so let's say we've been working for
console with console functions for a
while now and we want to step it up so
what's next well the dev tools have some
other really handy features namely the
dev tools debugger so the simplest way
to activate this is by adding the
debugger keyword to your code as you can
kind of see that I've done here where
it's highlighted and yeah when the
browser hits that keyword it will pause
the execution of your code and allow you
to inspect it so for example here I can
hover over the mysteries object and I
can log it out log out my local
variables in the console which I
wouldn't normally be able to do I can
inspect the entire scope of the code at
that point and I can also step through
my code line by line to further inspect
it so one tool that's almost essential
when using the debugger is black boxing
so this lets us prevent the debugger
from stepping into certain scripts when
we are debugging code so here I was
debugging a reacts life cycle function
like a component to mount or something
and I step through into the react on
library well I can be pretty confident
that my bugs not in here so a black box
the script this way the next time that I
stepped through a function that hits
that file the debugger will simply
ignore it and I can focus on my
application code you can also include
patterns in the div tool settings here
so I can black box entire folders like
node modules for instance so the dev
tools debugger has a crazy amount of
features I can't cover them all but yeah
so you can add breakpoints just on
certain event listeners like on the left
here so anytime I click on my browser a
breakpoint will be hit and I can inspect
the code at that point and you can also
do it when a Dom node is modified like
at the top here so this info box div if
I add this break on attribute
modifications it will break whenever a
class has changed or an attribute has
changed added or removed and you can
even add conditioner
break points so this means that your
code is only paused when a certain
condition is met this is really useful
for when a certain function say a react
render is called multiple times but the
first time it's called my mysteries data
here hasn't gonna isn't gonna have
anything in it because the API hasn't
returned yet and so I don't really care
about that point in the code so that's
why I've put a conditional breakpoint in
here to only break when there's actually
data there so I can inspect it so
sometimes we might be in a situation
where we have little to no control over
the code that we're debugging it might
be some JavaScript on an environment
that we can't reproduce locally or the
process of deploying our changes to our
remote environment might be really
frustrating and slow and painful
debugging a critical production issue is
stress City and so working working with
a tricky infrastructure makes that even
worse so say you have a version of your
application running locally using a
Chrome extension called resource over
add like I've got here I can proxy the
call that my production website is
making so in this case from bundle
jeaious on the left hand side - instead
load my local version of bandolce s
which i've got on localhost somewhere
what this means is that we can change
our code and test it within the larger
environment where the bug actually
occurred rather than the kind of false
environment that sometimes we have
locally applications like fiddler and my
favorite Charles proxy also allow you to
do this but with a lot more features
including the ability to monitor and
inspect all the calls at your site max
I've been on teams that have literally
used Charles proxy for their entire
front-end development flow because many
big applications are tricky to set up
locally and trying to keep the back in
architecture and the api's and your
front-end up-to-date across all
different teams is yeah it can be really
painful so if you have a reliable
staging environment then proxying your
front-end files is a nice way to skip
that set up entirely so a slightly
different approach
available in Canary make sure you first
enable override network requests and the
dev tools settings and then you can
click on the sources tab go to overrides
set up overrides and select a folder on
your hard drive and then give chrome
access to it and then make your changes
in the diff tools so here I'm gonna make
the reddit background couple and I'm
gonna save and you can see I've got this
purple dot now indicating that it's
being overridden and then when i refresh
the changes are persisted this can be
super useful
so yeah the previous solution using
proxies is great if you have a local
version of your code that you can map to
but this is perfect for when you don't
have that setup and you just want to
change something simple to test it so a
lot of the technology that I'm covering
either is seriously enhanced by or it
doesn't work at all really without
source Maps
so a quick refresh a source map is a
file that allows the browser or other
technology to map the compiled or
compressed code back to its original
file so yeah it's another really
important tool that helps us with
debugging minified code is pretty
impossible to debug properly so on the
top we're inspecting a website without
source maps you can see that all the
variables have been mangled and the es6
class has been transpired whereas on the
bottom source maps have been setup up
you can kind of see it here source map
from me and yeah it actually looks like
the code that we wrote depending on your
build process they're pretty easy to set
up and most importantly they only get
downloaded when you open the dev tools
so they won't affect your application or
its performance okay so that's the
browser
what about node well you can actually
debug node in the chrome dev tools you
just need to run your node scripts with
this flag and BRK by the way means to
break before your code starts so that
you can put your breakpoints in
straightaway and then you can either
click on this green node icon in any of
your dev tools windows or on the open
dedicated dev tools for node link
yeah and if you like this workflow then
you should check out the node inspection
manager extension which manages all your
scripts and your windows for you but
let's get to the really good stuff so
integrating debugging in the editor has
been around in various forms for ages
but many JavaScript developers are
either not aware of it they think that
it's too tricky to set up or they don't
want to change their debugging mindset
because they don't think it's worth it
well I'll let you be the judge just make
sure you give it a go first
so fortunately we have a lot more front
in focused editor options now some of
which included in both inbuilt debugger
so I'm gonna focus on vs code because I
love it it's really light and it's easy
to use and it's fast and it's what I use
every day and I promise I'm not trying
to sell you anything because I mean that
would be dumb because it's free but yeah
there are other ideas like webstorm
there also include an inbuilt debugger
and the idea is pretty similar so I'm
gonna take you through my debugging
process and how I set it up using a mini
front-end react app that talks to an
express server I've taken a couple of
edit a couple of spelling mistakes just
to simulate the idea of what it might
actually be like to debug a era so a
typical process for debugging a
front-end application might look
something like this we open the browser
we have an error in the console okay we
go to the editor console log out some of
the variables that we think might be
causing that error back to the browser
refresh or maybe a hot module reloading
[Music]
we've chosen a variable that helps us
determine how to fix the buck if we're
lucky back to the editor make the fix
back to the browser refresh ok great
finally fixed it's a hell of a lot of
guesswork and it's a lot of switching
back and forth so let's see how we can
improve that plot so Vere's code has a
bunch of extensions that let you debug
tons of different languages in different
frameworks the most useful for us is the
debugger for Chrome extension it's
actually a framework agnostic so you
could be using view or angular or jQuery
or whatever you like but I'm gonna show
you the configuration for my reactor so
first of all we go to extend
we look for the Chrome extension we
install it and then we reload vs code
it's super quick okay cool
let's go to the debugger and add a
configuration we just now need to look
for the chrome launch configuration and
the only thing we need to change here is
the URL and I'm changing it to localhost
3000 because that's what create react
app uses by default save that and press
play and with any luck tomorrow we have
our app and this is loaded with the
debugger really the debug absolutely no
other setup or settings anywhere and the
debugging experience is also really nice
so here we have a bug we've got the the
quotes are missing they're not showing
up so I'm gonna go into my editor and
add a breakpoint and then refresh and I
can see that some of the properties are
coming through but yeah a quote is
undefined okay that's weird
I'm gonna have a look in the code here
and go up a couple of levels and check
out my state so this is my react state
and there is a quote it's spelt with an
E okay great
go back into my code fix the bug remove
the breakpoint refresh magic fixed and I
literally didn't even touch the browser
so yeah similar situation occurs with
node so a typical workflow if we're
dealing with say a node API might be
something like this
we start with an error in the terminal
we switch to the editor write a console
log to check a variable we switch to
postman or another terminal to run curl
or a browser to run our app how would we
want to hit our API switch back to the
terminal to see the results if we're
lucky we can write a fix for it hit the
API again and hope our bug is fixed so
again we can really clean up this
workflow by doing so much more in the
editor here's how to set it up so I have
a bug on the right hand side server area
my mysteries route is not returning
anything and so I'm gonna add
another configuration and this time I'm
going to use the node launch program
configuration I don't have to change
anything because my entry point is fjs
and then I press play and my API is now
running I'm just going to quickly test
that by pinging it and hey it returns
pong okay great
so once we have that debugger running we
can hit this broken mysteries in point
with our react application and easily
debug what's going on in our node API so
I'm gonna add a breakpoint to my
mysteries routes refresh to hit it and
you can see everything looks legit okay
we're getting the request through
correctly so I'm gonna step through my
code everything looks fine not ah okay
we've had an error mysterious is not
fine okay apparently I'm a terrible
speller so I'm gonna go through and fix
my bug remove the breakpoint refresh and
then hit the API again by refreshing my
app and it's fixed check so the even
coolest thing is that vs code will let
you make compound configurations meaning
that you can debug your front and your
back-end code at the same time over
multiple and different languages and
frameworks so yeah one more thing before
I finish I should just quickly mention
that in no way have I covered this space
I've obviously had to focus on one
browser and one IDE and I didn't even
touch on mobile performance HTTP
debugging just to name a few there's
there's so much more to explore and of
course accurate and realistic test
coverage is an extremely important and
useful way to prevent bugs in the first
place also provide a quick and easy way
to test fixes and prevent bugs from
occurring again so the golden rule is
once you fixed a bug make sure there's a
test for it so the last thing I'm gonna
leave you with is this if for some
reason you're gonna stick with
console.log that's fine just make sure
you write a good snippet for it
and that's it thanks very much
[Applause]